fliegen wird teurer bahn fahren
günstiger das kabinett billigt weitere
teile des umstrittenen klimapakets
türkische offensive in nordsyrien
präsident erdogan weist forderung nach
waffenruhe zurück rätselhafte fall in
den niederlanden wurde eine familie
jahrelang auf einem bauernhof gefangen
gehalten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
barbara hahlweg guten abend und ein
herzliches willkommen norbert könig es
auch dabei für den sport mit fußball und
tennis genommen vor einem monat hat die
bundesregierung ihr paket zum
klimaschutz vorgestellt jetzt bringt sie
nach und nach die entsprechenden gesetze
auf den weg heute unter anderem neue
steuern die klimafreundliches verhalten
fördern sollen
auf der einen seite werden tanken und
heizen teurer ebenso das fliegen vor
allem auf kurzstrecken an anderer stelle
dagegen wird entlastet mit einer höheren
pendlerpauschale und günstigeren
zugtickets was das finanziell ausmacht
zeigt oliver flammen
der tägliche weg zur arbeit kostet zeit
und geld
umso mehr je weiter die anfahrt ist ab
dem 21 kilometer steigt die
pendlerpauschale deshalb von 30 auf 35
cent pro kilometer
wer beispielsweise 40 kilometer zur
arbeit fährt kann künftig pro jahr 220
euro mehr als werbungskosten absetzen
auch geringverdiener die oft keine
steuererklärung abgeben und deshalb von
der erhöhung der pendlerpauschale nicht
profitieren werden unterstützt sie
bekommen eine mobilitäts prämie von 4,9
cent pro kilometer
bahntickets werden im fernverkehr
günstiger dort sinkt die mehrwertsteuer
von 19 auf 7 prozent eine zugfahrt von
münchen nach berlin kostet derzeit 153
euro
künftig kommt sie auf rund 138 euro
fliegen dagegen eher teurer und das vor
allem auf kurz und mittelstrecken
die luftverkehrsabgabe wird um bis zu 74
prozent angehoben der steueranteil liegt
dann je nach flugstrecke zwischen 13 und
59 euro
wie stark die ticketpreise steigen hängt
davon ab inwieweit die
fluggesellschaften die steuererhöhungen
an die kunden weitergeben
die resonanz auf das heutige paket ist
ziemlich verheerend
pillepalle und wahllose einzelmaßnahmen
schimpfen grüne fdp und linke sozial
ungerecht kritisieren sozialverbände
wettbewerbsverzerrend sagt die luftfahrt
aus berlin patricia wiedemeier es geht
jetzt doch recht schnell die koalition
drückt aufs tempo mit der verabschiedung
gleich mehrere gesetzentwürfe mit
konkreten steuerlichen anreizen für mehr
klimaschutz
alles zusammen also ein paket das dazu
beitragen wird dass der klimawandel
aufgehalten werden kann dass der
klimawandel durch diese maßnahmen
wirklich aufgehalten werden kann
die opposition ist das skeptisch
bundesregierungen verfällt in absoluten
klima aktivismus ohne sinnvoll zu prüfen
ob zb einer co2 steuer die eingeführt
werden soll
auch verfassungsrechtlich durchgehen
kann zudem geht es heute eigentlich in
der hauptsache um steuererhöhungen
höhere steuern auf flugtickets mehr
pendlerpauschale günstigere bahntickets
das alleine reiche nicht die linke
fordert unter anderem mehr investitionen
in die bahn wir haben ja bei der
bankenkrise gesehen dass über die banken
ein riesiger rettungsschirm ausgespannt
wurde uns von 480 milliarden euro
man müsste auch über das klima ein
rettungsschirm aufspannen um zu zeigen
dass man es ernst meint zu niedrig sei
zudem der geplante einstiegspreis für
den co2 ausstoß von zehn euro pro tonne
kritisieren wissenschaftler und
opposition
die bundesregierung bleibt mit ihrem
maßnahmen hinter dem zurück was
klimapolitisch notwendig wäre und was
gesellschaftlich möglich wäre
trotz aller kritik nächste woche schon
sollen die gesetzentwürfe in den
bundestag und bundesrat eingebracht
werden weitere gesetze zum beispiel zur
kfz steuer sollen in kürze folgen
nach langem ringen gibt es beim thema
grundsteuer eine einigung neben der
koalition wollen jetzt auch fdp und
grüne die reform mittragen
damit steht die dafür notwendige
zweidrittelmehrheit im bundestag
abgestimmt wird am freitag
künftig soll die grundsteuer nach
bodenwert und miete berechnet werden
diese steuer spiel jährlich etwa 14
milliarden euro in die kassen der
kommunen nach nordsyrien alle
diplomatischen versuche die offensive
der türkei zu stoppen sind bisher
verpufft präsident erdogan sagte die von
den usa angedrohten sanktionen
bereiteten ihm keine sorgen
den deutschen außenminister maß
beleidigte er als dilettanten
deutschland will waffenverkäufe an
ankara einschränken
ziel der türkei ist eine so genannte
sicherheitszone die armee trifft aber
offenbar auf heftigen widerstand der
gruppen zum beispiel in russia leim
glück weil kurz berichtet
in ras allein wird heftig gekämpft mit
der türkei verbündete arabische
freischärler gehen dort gegen kurdische
gpg kräfte vor obwohl der generalstab in
ankara und am letzten wochenende
gemeldet hatte die stadt sei unter
türkischer kontrolle
diese bilder hier sollen belegen dass
weiter östlich im ort therapie hat
inzwischen nicht mehr gekämpft wird vor
den angreifenden türkischen truppen
haben sich kurdische milizen hier
zurückgezogen
bei der fraktionssitzung seiner akp
parteien ankara wurde staatspräsident
erdogan für seine militäroffensive heute
mit stehendem applaus bejubelt
erdogan betonte die türkei könne niemals
eine waffenruhe erklären verhandlungen
mit der kurdischen gpg lehnte er ab
unser vorschlag für ein ende der
offensive ist alle terroristen legen
ihre waffen nieder und verlassen bis
heute abend die sicherheitszonen morgen
werden us-vizepräsident pence und
außenminister pompeo zu verhandlungen
mit erdogan in ankara erwartet
soldaten der us-armee haben unterdessen
in man beach westlich des euphrat eine
einnahme der stadt durch die türken
verhindert unterstützt von russischen
einheiten auf einer woche wäre es
unmöglich gewesen mit russischer flagge
durch man beach zu fahren da
kontrollierten us-dollar an die stadt
die sind jetzt weg ihre zurückgelassenen
stützpunkte haben die russen übernommen
im benachbarten nordirak sind inzwischen
die ersten von mehr als 160.000
flüchtlinge in einem auffanglager der
vereinten nationen eingetroffen
unter den flüchtlingen sind fast 70.000
kinderhilfsorganisationen sind weiterhin
vor ort um die menschen mit trinkwasser
essen und medizin zu versorgen
wenn sie helfen wollen können sie
spenden stichwort zdf nothilfe syrien
die bahn de 65 104 106 100 104 106 100
alle infos auch unter spenden punkt
zdf.de oder im zdf text auf seite 8 190
die unsichere lage in nordsyrien macht
auch den sicherheitsbehörden hierzulande
sorgen sie fürchten auch deutsches
kämpfer könnten aus den gefängnissen
dort fliehen
deshalb wird nun eine alte forderung neu
diskutiert deutschland soll es
terroristen mit deutschem pass zurück
holen und hier vor gericht stellen
armin coerper aus berlin das ist martin
lemke aus sachsen-anhalt wir treffen ihn
in einem kurdischen gefängnis in syrien
lemke soll für den islamischen staat
gefoltert und gemordet haben jetzt will
er nach hause
tausende kämpfer wie lemke haben die
kurden gefangen genommen darunter etwa
40 deutsche mehrere hundert sind in den
letzten tagen bereits geflohen
ein leichtes könnte es jetzt für sie
seien sich in den strom der flüchtlinge
zu mischen aus nordsyrien in richtung
europa es ist natürlich absehbar dass
menschen mit sozialen bezügen in
deutschland sich auf den weg machen
wieder zurück nach deutschland und
deshalb ist das unverzeihlich dass die
bundesregierung diese leute nicht
einfach geholt hat und hier vor gericht
gestellt
auch niedersachsens innenminister sagt
heute in einem zeitungsinterview
politisch will niemand ihr es anhänger
zurücknehmen rechtlich besteht bei
deutschen staatsangehörigen aber nun
einmal die verpflichtung das zu tun
abdel karim omar ist ein vertreter der
syrischen kurden er will mit deutschland
auch über die rückführung der kämpfer
sprechen ohne erfolg auch dem zdf
gegenüber will sich heute kein
zuständiger minister äußern
stattdessen an verbaler slalomlauf wir
pflegen mit verschiedenen politischen
kräften in syrien politische kontakte
damit ist aber nicht eine irgendwie
geartete völkerrechtliche anerkennung
heutiger politischer strukturen
verbunden auch etwa 60 deutsche kinder
von aes kämpfern sind noch immer in
syrischen lagern sie rechtzeitig vor dem
krieg in sicherheit zu bringen die zeit
dafür hat die bundesregierung
verstreichen lassen
zum wechselt zwei wochen vor dem
geplanten austritt großbritanniens
laufen die gespräche zwischen den
unterhändlern in brüssel auf hochtouren
ein durchbruch bis zum eu-gipfel morgen
scheint tatsächlich noch möglich aus eu
kreisen heißt es ein neuer braig cit
vertrag sei so gut wie fertig anne
gellinek in brüssel stimmt das es deutet
vieles darauf hin dass in den letzten
stunden die verbliebenen stolpersteine
aus dem weg geräumt werden konnten
gerade eben ist eu chefunterhändler
michel barnier hier im ratsgebäude
eingetroffen er will die 27 anderen
botschafter der mitglied der eu
mitgliedsstaaten informieren über den
stand der dinge bei den verhandlungen
bis zuletzt kreisten die gespräche um
technische probleme zum zoll status in
nordirland und auch um die inner
britische zustimmung zu diesem abkommen
namentlich die der nordirischen
regionalpartei die jubi wenn also diese
stolpersteine jetzt ausgeräumt sind dann
könnte der eu-gipfel morgen mit boris
johnson darüber diskutieren welche art
von verlängerung jetzt notwendig ist um
das abkommen noch durch die beiden
parlamente das britische und das
europäische zu bringen und hier lauert
aus eu-sicht die nächste gefahr
kahn boris johnson ist wirklich schaffen
das abkommen durch britische unterhaus
zu bringen also ein vertrag scheint
greifbar nah aber über die ziellinie ist
ja noch nicht vielen dank für diese
informationen aus brüssel anne gellinek
und noch eine nachricht aus brüssel
eigentlich sollte die neue eu-kommission
mit ursula von allein an der spitze am
ersten november starten daraus wird
nichts weil das eu-parlament 3 von 26
designierten kommissare abgelehnt hat
frankreich rumänien und ungarn müssen
jetzt neue kandidaten präsentieren
möglicher neuer starttermin ist anfang
dezember
wie konnte das so lange unentdeckt
bleiben das ist nur eine der vielen
fragen die der fall einer familie in den
niederlanden aufwirft offenbar wurde
dort ein vater mit seinen fünf
erwachsenen kindern jahrelang auf einem
bauernhof gefangen gehalten
wegen des verdachts der
freiheitsberaubung haben die behörden
den mieter des hofs festgenommen
gunnar krüger berichtet ein hof und ein
fragezeichen weniger am nachmittag nennt
die justiz auf twitter einen tatverdacht
freiheitsberaubung und
gesundheitsgefährdung errichtet sich
gegen einen 58 jährigen aus österreich
den niederlanden als tischlerarbeiten
soll zur stunde durchsucht die polizei
zwei ladenlokale im benachbarten schloss
der einsatz stehe in verbindung zu den
ermittlungen ausgelöst wurden sie nach
dem einer der söhne die dorfkneipe
besucht hatte havanna er sagte er sei
seit neun jahren nicht draußen gewesen
er hatte keine ahnung wo er war war sein
machte das hat man sofort gesehen sagte
direktor der wird wählte den notruf
polizisten trafen den vater und seine
erwachsenen kinder in einem
verschließbaren raum an zunächst blieb
unklar ob die familie dort freiwillig
lebte was die menschen die dort wohnten
wirklich gemacht haben ist teil unserer
untersuchung wir haben viele fragen auf
die wir noch keine antwort haben
am donnerstag will der
untersuchungsrichter über die vorführung
des tatverdächtigen informieren
vielleicht gibt es dann wieder ein
fragezeichen weniger
das land der frankfurter buchmesse ist
dieses jahr norwegen einsame
landschaften dünn besiedelt der mord
vielleicht nur einen fjord weit entfernt
krimis aus dem hohen norden faszinieren
und fesseln gerade auch deutsche leser
nur was macht diese krimis so besonders
die langen und kalten nächte die wilde
natur wird heißen auf spurensuche
er könnte es gewesen sein
der mörder ist unauffällig doch
auffällig oft taucht er auf in der
norwegischen literatur viele krimis der
weltspitze kommen aus dem kleinen land
warum bloß die kriminalitätsrate sehr
niedrig was ist da passiert nicht sehr
viel gefehlt bis auf den straßen
es ist realitätsflucht und es ist es ist
es keine wirklichkeit und ich denke das
hängt schon damit zusammen dass so viele
krimis geschrieben werden wir haben
lange winter wie viel regen fällt schnee
und da kommt natürlich auch das
geschichtenerzählen her
die krimiautoren halten der
oberflächlich so heil wirkenden
gesellschaft norwegens einen unruhigen
spiegel vor
im pavillon des gastlandes gibt es den
tod sogar als geruchsprobe ich das nach
toter großmutter es riecht alt es riecht
sehr alt aber nicht abstoßend es ist so
ein bisschen
dieses holz vom sarg finde ich
ein bisschen raus spüren wohl am
bekanntesten hierzulande sind die krimis
von jo nesbo sein kommissar ist dem
alkohol verfallen und gerade wegen
dieser schwäche lieben ihn holen die
leser ich habe mit der polizei in oslo
gesprochen die sag mir in meinen krimis
sei alles realistisch bis auf die
tatsache dass sie immer betrunken sind
nein ich denke nicht dass der typische
norwegische polizist ein säufer ist
norwegens krimis sie führen uns oft in
traumhafte landschaften und
alptraumhafte menschliche abgründe
jetzt wissen wir auch dass die norweger
humor haben zum schutz seiner arbeit
genau mit einer nachwuchs
nationalmannschaft auf erfolgskurs
die nach dem verlorenen em-finale
neuformierte u21 auswahl bleibt
ungeschlagen im zweiten
qualifikationsspiel zur nächsten
europameisterschaft gab es in bosnien
herzegowina den zweiten sieg 2 0 für das
team von trainer stefan kunz in der 29
minute bedarf es eines torwartfehlers
zur längst fälligen deutschen führung
kovacevic kann einen schuss von timm
handwerker nicht festhalten und schenkt
den paderborner luca kilian den ersten
treffer für die gäste
da deutschland in dem schalker markus
schubert auf den klar besten und
torhüter zählen kann steht ihrer
deutlich schwächeren zweiten hälfte
hinten auch weiterhin die 0 ehe dann in
der 79 minute der wolfsburger lukas
meter mit dem 2 0 für die entscheidung
sorgte nach einem insgesamt
durchwachsenen spiel gegen bosnien
herzegowina klettert das team von
trainer stefan kunz in seiner
em-qualifikationsgruppe an die
tabellenspitze
am wochenende halbfinale in linz und
jetzt erfolgreicher auftakt in luxemburg
tennisprofi andrea petkovic ist im
aufwärtstrend die 32 jährige an dem
herzogtum das achtelfinale erreicht und
freut sich auch auf neue aufgaben
abseits des courts
der erste satz ist zum vergessen
petkovic verliert ihn 0 zu 6 gegen die
gute hartplatz spielerin camila giorgi
aus italien aber das mit dem vergessen
klappt ganz gut trotz des dick
bandagierten knie slas die 32 jährige
darmstädterin den schwachen anfang
hinter sich kommt zum satzausgleich und
im umkämpften dritten satz zur 5 4
führung
die nutzt sie konsequent und gewinnt das
match mit 0 6 6 4 und 6 zu 4
in der nächsten runde trifft sie auf
antonia lottner aus düsseldorf
darüber hinaus wird sie sich ende des
jahres einer neuen aufgabe widmen als
moderatorin im zdf sonntags in der zdf
sportreportage wird man sie sehen können
erste auftritte gibt es im dezember
kostproben ihres talents hatte sich
schon als gast im aktuellen sportstudio
abgegeben freuen wir uns und sagen
herzlich willkommen oder absolut liegen
zum schluss noch ein blick ins
astronauten leben so ungelenk sah das
noch 1969 bei den apollo astronauten auf
dem mond aus die anzüge ließen kaum
bewegungsfreiheit und so sieht es
künftig aus nasa ingenieur in kristin
davis stellt excel vor den anzug für
geschmeidiges arbeiten im all
losgelöst von allen text ihren zwängen
und in einheitsgröße die männern und die
gewinnzahlen lauten 5 912 17 31 38 und
die superzahl 8 weitere gewinnzahlen
finden sie auf lotto punkt zdf.de und
dem zdf text auf seite 55 7
der herbst zeigt sich morgen von seiner
rauen seite eher grauen seite wo sie
denn noch die sonne sehen können erklärt
gleich katja und zum vorziehen freut
sich christian sie was auf sie im heute
journal
wir sind morgen wieder da wenn sie mögen
machen sie sich noch einen schönen abend
auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren das ist mal
ein richtig großes tief das tief thilo
das überdeckt island norwegen schweden
bis spanien und es bringt uns aussieht
westeuropa eher milde temperaturen und
regen heute nacht regnet es entlang der
küsten von ost und nordsee und zwischen
dem emsland und dem oberrhein
sonst bleibt es meist trocken an der
donau bildet sich nebel
richtig klar wird die nacht am alpenrand
und dort genauso wie niederbayern sinken
die temperaturen auf 3 bis 2 grad es
kann also bodenfrost geben
deutlich milder bleibt die nacht
zwischen der elbe und dem niederrhein
und 14 bis 12 grad und morgen liegen
dann die höchsttemperaturen meist
zwischen 14 und 17 grad
aber zwischen der lausitz und dem
oberrhein und südöstlich davon steigen
die werte auf 16 bis 20 grad und jetzt
haben sie wahrscheinlich schon eine idee
wo ist morgen am sonnigsten wird das ist
nämlich genau dort wo es auch am
wärmsten wird am sonnigsten ist es dabei
am alpenrand
anders sieht es aus zwischen der moose
und der ostseeküste da regnet es immer
mal wieder an der nordsee kommt die
sonne allerdings zum vorschein und in
den nächsten tagen geht es wechselhaft
und mild weiter schönen abend noch